all times
are filled with immense uncertainty
there's never been a time in history
ever that ever had certainty ever
and so i find it funny when people say
during these uncertain times nothing
like all time is uncertain
and so the question is is how does one
enjoy uncertain times
um and what questions do you raise
and so i think asking questions like
what good will come from this decision
or
how long will this decision last
these are the things that i think are
important which is are we prepared for
the definite uncertainty
do we have insurance
do we have savings are we taking care of
our people you know are we taking care
of our families are we taking care of
our community you cannot judge the
quality of a crew by how a ship performs
in calm waters you can only judge the
quality of a crew by how a ship performs
in rough waters in fact very often we
actually don't know
the strength of a team or a family or
community until there are rough waters
we actually don't know how good our
culture is until we face
a crisis and so the question is are you
laying a foundation
that is more likely to produce a team or
a group of people or a community that
will come together rather than abandon
and save themselves
and so asking yourselves this question
going uh with with the complete
understanding that all time is uncertain
and how do we guard guard for the future
you know the best companies save money
the best companies in the in the good
times don't distribute all the money
away for bonuses you know but they see
they save a lot so that when those hard
times come they're flush with cash to
take care of uh people so to manage
through
through the hard times
the problem with that concept is it has
the word back in it
you know there's no going backwards ever
and life politics culture technology
uh tastes
change with time they evolve
um
you you know and and and especially um
things like a pandemic like a global
pandemic of course they're gonna change
who we are
um you know the people who went into the
second world war were not the people who
came out of the second world war and
there was no going back
um and and we're the same what i'm
fascinated by
is
how it'll affect young people i think
for older people we'll go back into some
of our old habits even though new ones
may have been formed um but if you think
about it kids who grew up during the
depression
or doing during the war for example you
know our many of our
grandparents
uh or parents if uh uh you know who
lived through those times for the rest
of their lives they were frugal and
miserly well there's nothing wrong with
them
it's because they lived through the
depression you know they lived through
the so they they saved every they
continue to save every jam jar and reuse
every piece of tin foil you know
[Music]
and it's the same like i'm fascinated by
kids who went through the pandemic
during these formative years
um you know 10 11 12 13
what strange habits they will cling on
to for the rest of their lives there's
no way to know and you know for the next
10 or 20 years
that their grandkids will make fun of
them for something that they do that was
formed now
there is liability associated with you
know that kids who are supposed to be
social who weren't social um you know
will they be more shy will they be more
afraid i mean we've seen this happen
with kids who just
you know who are who have their heads
down on their phones and become addicted
to
technology that
you know i i know somebody who they're
teenagers afraid of answering the front
door because there might be a stranger
there you know um you know
so who knows and i think we have to be
aware of it so that we can we can
compensate as best we can for the
socialization but there might be new
skills perhaps they'll be better at
reading someone's emotions just from
their eyes because they haven't had the
benefit of their mouth you know and
their expressions
uh so who knows what what they may
become way more sophisticated and better
making eye contact
a creative type
an infinite minded thinker embraces
uncertainty and surprise and finds
opportunity in the unknown
um the sort of finite mindedness
fears uncertainty and surprise and uh
and i so when you ask me what does
creativity look like in a social setting
trying to go recreate what was
um in a new world is not creativity you
know trying to do just the way we did
things but online is not creativity um
saying okay let's pretend we're starting
from scratch this is how the world works
now there's a larger online dimension
which we never had um there are new
things that we have to guard for and
against um
uh how if we were starting from scratch
what would it look like
and i think that's where creativity
can be ignited
which is we are we don't feel limited
by the way we used to do things nor do
we feel a pressure to recreate the way
we did things there may be great things
from the past that we want to bring
along with us but there may be some
stuff that we want to let go of as well
this is that opportunity um and i think
a lack of creativity is is just trying
to cling on cling on to the past um you
know we don't want to put these
organizations in formaldehyde where we
simply try and preserve what was we
whether it whether with or without a
global pandemic as i said before you
know times change technology change
culture changes politics change taste
change and so any organization that
wants to stay relevant has to adapt with
the times um
you know
things like a pandemic or any other kind
of
stress or chaos
maybe expedite that